it's all right so the double headers for
the phillies so far have not gone all
that well but they're gonna have plenty
of practice including today against the
red sox they have five double headers
remaining including this afternoon
zach efflux would have to be the
carefulest 2-1 with a 4.45 earned run
average
johnny's had a couple good starts and a
couple of starts where he's allowed four
earned runs or more roduko is hitting
311 with five home runs and 13 runs
batted in once you pitch swag and a miss
he got him one way
that's a good start seven pitch at that
but
ends the way zach hoped it would end
ever as the battery
had a call strike three 95 on that
sinker back-to-back strikeouts for
effluent martin perez the lefty well
he's pitched better than that two and
four record hasn't got a lot of run
support and it's coming off one of the
greatest six innings you could pitch
lost to no hitter but was superb for six
innings and mccutcheon to lead things
off
one two and got him to offer it that he
struck him out that was 83 miles an hour
rio muto the designated hitter 262 of 10
home runs
lofted into right pretty well hit racing
back for dugo on the track he's got it
over the shoulder for out number three
no score after one
as vazquez will lead it off against zach
eflin
they'll tap that one to third charging
bomb on the throw it's going to be close
and he's not going to get him and so
vazquez is on with a base hit
now jackie bradley jr is a little
different player this time than when the
phillies are up at fedway park he's
hitting nine straight
so we're gonna miss
three strikeouts for effort a very rare
change up from zach efling
good time to use it verdugo struck out
his first time up
maybe one day good
retired here in the second no runs two
hits both infield hits
middle of the second scoreless game
dd 263 with five home runs
o2 pitch
in the air to right center field going
back on it is verdugo it is gone
the home run for dede
is sixth of the year and the phillies
take a one-nothing lead
nice swing yeah that ball was just
elevated too much by perez the bases are
loaded
and here is hoskins
and that one's spanked on a line coming
in to make the play is chavis in left
field
and perez survives one-nothing philly
as debors leads thing off here leads
things off here in the third inning
2-2 there's a bullet that one's shot to
right that is going to get out of here
in a hurry off the toyota sign
raffy devers has tied it with authority
and it's a 1-1 game wow oh we don't need
that we don't need tape measure we need
the gun how hard was that ball hit exit
velocity sanders staying hot with a bat
fourth strikeout for eplin
jackie bradley struck out his first epad
and a call strike three on the inside
corner 95 five strikeouts for zach
side is retired here in the third a run
does score on the home run by devers
it's a 1-1 game
third is harper now you get
an error a wild pitch
fast ball
you gotta run
they throw behind the word it's over his
head and he's gonna score the phillies
will take a 2-1 lead
all kinds of ways they can score
that's guess i really had no chance no
chance no chance of getting it
up runners on first and second
back toward the middle and that'll leak
into center field to base it two runs
will score alec balm continues his solid
hitting with runners in scoring position
he's now 10 for 22
and the phillies lead it four
one out and grounded out to second over
bernough
to
two
that one's ripped
way deep to right field watch this one
sail that ball is gone into the second
tank alex verdugo with his sixth home
run of the season and the red sox are
back on the scoreboard so red sox pulled
it in two against eflin
he's gonna fire that one the opposite
field that's a deep drive that's back
there
and that ball is gone
red sox go back to back to polar within
one rafael devers with his second blast
using the whole ballpark stall back with
a walk he's also grounded to the pitcher
i fly ball left field deep turning
mccutchen and kiss that one goodbye
so bobby dalback with number four it's
gonna roll around on the concourse out
there and the red sox have tied it
on the strength of four home runs today
so if rafael blasts another one here it
would be his third home run in a row
high fly ball that one pretty well hit
backing up harper at the wall leaping he
can't get it it's off the fence here
comes the run in to score bradugo will
touch home plate
so no home run this time he just missed
that one but he's got himself a double
and the red sox have the lead five to
four well that'll bring up bryce harper
and
gonna hit a high fly ball but not
terribly deep
jackie bradley jr there to make the
catch two men left
two outs and it's left to ball and the
pitch coming
and a line drive base it to left field
one run is in here comes dede the throw
to the plate is not in time
the bills once again come from behind
and win it